[Music]
foreign
I'm sorry what was that ready Freddy
you're ready well that's great Dr
Wallach I'm ready as well let's go ahead
and open up the doors here in our Zoom
room hello everybody and welcome to
daily with Doc my name is Becca Dukes I
am the uh I'm well I'm very honored to
be the hostess of this program where we
are bringing empowering information that
allows you as an individual to have the
freedoms because of knowledge to make
choices that not only are common sense
when you know that there's other options
but facts that they are empowering their
bill building up rather than suppressing
or breaking down so folks welcome to
daily with Doc if you would like to join
us live in our Zoom room we are at Daily
with
doczoom.com Monday through Friday from
12 to 12 50 p.m yes I know it's kind of
odd hours but that is 12 to 12 50 p.m
Pacific time so straight up noon here on
the West Coast we bring this information
to you that is three o'clock to 3 50 if
you're on the Eastern side of the
country and around the world we can be
heard in your local time zone that is um
whatever is equivalent to 12 p.m Pacific
time so hello and welcome if you're out
on any of the different platforms that
we are streaming please make sure that
you like our Channel and send us a hello
in the comments let us know that you are
there let us know what country you are
joining us from because we love to see
all the different countries all the
people waking up around the world
wanting information that empowers them
to make better choices when it comes to
their Health and Wellness
now if you're here live with us in the
zoom room you have the opportunity to
raise your hand and ask questions as I
will be calling on people in the order
that their hand is raised
after Dr wellick gives his opening
monologue so go to that Zoom menu look
at the reactions and raise hand is where
you will find that option there if you
are on the phone and joining us if you
do star six it will unmute you if you do
star nine it will raise your hand so
raise your hand star nine okay and then
when you're done you can do star nine
again it lowers your hand and then when
you're called upon you can do star six
to unmute so I love the fact that we
have that available now as well for
those who are on the radio and who we're
used to calling Into the Dead Doctors
Don't Lie radio program
you can still call in
go to zoom dot daily withdoczoom.com
and it'll bring up the program but if it
better yet go to daily withdoc.com sign
up for our newsletter you will get an
invitation to the program that includes
the call-in information so daily
withdoc.com sign up for our newsletter
and you will get your personal
invitation into daily with dog Zoom so
with that being said hello everybody
let's go ahead and I would love to
introduce to you one of the founding
fathers of the science of epigenetics
the science that gave me hope that I was
not stuck with diseases just because
all of my
ancestors before me my my grandmother my
grandfather my mother and my father
anything that they had
epigenetics gave me that hope that I
don't have to end up where they are when
it comes to poor health I like the good
stuff but let's leave the bad stuff
behind folks because
it does not serve us so let's look to
the things that do serve us with the
science of the epigenetics one of the
founding fathers of the science who has
Decades of research in pathology not
just searching and researching but
actually almost or over 30 000 autopsies
that he has looked at participated and
been the lead pathologist on
in his many years of having this passion
to help Humanity he started out by
getting a Bachelor of Science in
agriculture and soil went in to become a
doctor of veterinary medicine where he
treated animals around the world
and the lead pathologist on many
oh man
Monumental Expeditions ex like saving
the right wine white rhino that's kind
of monumental
and with three post-doctorates he was
teaching nutrition
at the college level and then be decided
after being fired for finding the first
non-human case of cystic fibrosis in a
monkey he decided to go back to school
and become a naturopathic physician so
he could be here with us and give us
information to help ourselves as humans
so folks please help me welcome Dr Joel
Wallach Dr Wallach welcome to daily with
Doc
well thank you so much for the kind
introduction Becca and thank you team
for all being here to appreciate you I
know there's a lot of stuff going on and
um
it's one of those things where
um it's a never-ending story uh the big
story today I think is Bruce Willis
famous movie actor and movie producer
Bruce Willis and he's been diagnosed
with FTD frontal temporal dementia which
is only first identified a couple of I
don't know not even a year ago okay and
it's kind of a variation of Alzheimer's
disease because it's one of these
demyelinating diseases where the white
matter of the brain goes away
Alzheimer's disease multiple sclerosis
gambaray syndrome Parkinson's disease
FTD frontal Temple dementia which is
Bruce Willis cjd
um let's see here
um
kreutchfield Jacobs disease which is
also known as mad cow disease
same same symptoms same
um pathology in the white man of the
brain ALS amalotropic mouserosis Lou
Gehrig's Disease the same thing
and then
um there's kind of a not a new entity
it's just been made a new entity because
you know I used to see this stuff in the
wild animals it's called CWD chronic
wasting disease and deer and buffalo and
giraffe and in the in the eastern part
of Africa and so forth
these things are all the same pathology
it's just by dumb luck what part of the
brain is more severely impacted and so
you get different symptoms but it's all
the same disease
okay and if there's anything I can offer
there that's something to offer there
are no such things as prions I always
you know I'm a pathologist I've seen
every kind of bacteria fungus and yeast
virus you can think of
but nobody can show me a picture of a
prion and they keep saying all this
chronic wasting disease in Deer is
caused by prions no
um and Parkinson's disease is one of
those uh terrible terrible diseases of
Aging no
okay they're all the same diseases it's
again location location location
and
we have so much experience in animals
and in animals you know like these herds
of deer that a thousand head of deer in
these big ranches and four of them will
have CWD chronic wasting disease and
um you get these these people who are
really they're not all right upstairs in
their head they want to
um uh Ashley
eliminate kill all one thousand deer
because they're afraid they're going to
catch the CWD from the four deer that
have it well the CWD chronic wasting
disease is not an infectious disease
it's identical in pathology when you
look at the pathology under the
microscope of Alzheimer's disease MS
multiple sclerosis gambarre syndrome
Parkinson's disease FTD found temporal
dementia like Bruce Willis has Chrysler
Jacobs disease ALS Lou Gehrig's Disease
CWD and in ruminance it could be Buffalo
and deer and giraffe and
Antelope all over the world
it's the same pathology
it looks the same okay whether it's a
whether it's a deer or a human or a
giraffe okay
um or an antelope and so it's just
location location which gives you the
different symptoms it's just like when
you have arthritis if you have arthritis
in your knees are you going to have
different symptoms then you when you
have arthritis in your shoulders uh well
yeah
okay but it's the same disease okay and
so why would it show up in somebody's
shoulders when they have arthritis in
every joint in their body well because
maybe that's what they do for a living
they're lifting boxes and loading and
unloading trucks and so they're working
their shoulders more than they're
working either joint
and so this is just see this in athletes
athletes tend to have a lot of stuff
going on
in their knees their hips because
they're running and squatting and
lifting and dodging and all this kind of
stuff and so that's why you see
different types of
um arthritis in in different parts of
the body but it's the same disease okay
and so we came out with a book it's all
in your head
and I don't know 25 26 pages and each
chapter goes into the pathology of a one
of the 12 pairs of cranial nerves okay
and so and then the spinal cord we have
a a
uh CD that goes along with the book by
the same title and it deals primarily
with his final chord and all the various
symptoms and diseases you get when the
spinal cord gets squeezed by the skull
the osteoporosis is a skull doctors were
never taught this in school
and I was seeing all this at the autopsy
table and they're mentioned osteoporosis
of the skull by the clinical medical
doctors and so I decided to do the
research and and do the book in the CD
and there you have it okay and so that's
why we we're at we're at so I cannot
thank our team enough because they're
making a great great positive impact
and of course all of these diseases are
preventable those are nutritional
deficiency diseases all these diseases
reversible because of nutritional
deficiency it is and we have some stuff
going on with patients who are also our
patient but also at rush the university
okay and so on
and so it's one of those things where
we're going to have some great great
great great great
um pieces in in our new flip chart
coming out I'm very excited about that
of course the flip chart
is a presentation tool the flip chart is
a presentation tool
um the flip chart doesn't have
75 chapters in it you know or 50
chapters in it like books like every
genetics and rare earth wind cures and
um Dead Doctors Don't Lie and so forth
it's a different different thing the the
again
the um
clip chart is a presentation
to get information to groups of people
who need to hear this and then you get
the book and then you read the details
okay in in the books but um in in the in
the flip chart we're going to have a
book The Wallach Revolution is going to
be part of the flip chart
and so that way people kind of know our
background or 75 years of research and
everything will be highlighted uh in
that book the wallet Revolution which is
part of the flip chart material and
we're so close to you know
um we have all these emails from
from the printers today we haven't had a
chance to look at the email sheds but
I'm sure it's a good news and they're
they're ready to go how many do we want
to print and so forth but this is going
to
change the world the flip charts along
with all the books we have
is going to change the world because
there's so much
false information out there and we have
the unimpeachable truth okay and of
course then we have the
um education brochures
with pictures of covers of all our
best-selling books
and uh
paragraphs should tell you what's in
those books and if you buy 10 of any one
of those books at the same time you get
a nice discount
and this is how you grow your youngevity
business this is how you grow your
family this is how you help your family
or the doctors have failed you okay you
will be able to help your families
because of these books and CDs and DVDs
oh and also the flip chart okay so this
is a new tool it's kind of like when the
um
piston engine came along with vehicles
we were able to move away from horses
pulling wagons okay and now we have
these big big trucks they're 50 foot
long or 100 foot long
and carry a hundred tons of stuff where
horse pulling a wagon could pull Maybe
two tons okay and so this is we're
getting there to where this is going to
be breaking
the news very quickly when this flip
chart comes out
and I'm so excited about it
and you know some of your your favorite
youngevity
uh leaders are highlighted in this lip
chart because they have done so many
great things it was obvious to put them
in there with some of the great things
they've done so with that said let's see
here I'm going to go back to uh
Becca here
all right thank you Dr Wallach and folks
the Wallach Revolution that is actually
the now authorized Auto uh biography of
Dr Wallach and what he has done up to
2016 which includes all of the times
that he has sued the FDA and prevailed
and got those nutrients added into
things like prenatal vitamins and baby
formula folks beginning of Life he has
been fighting for The Unborn Child for
many many years and helping build
stronger communities starting before
birth so I'm excited about the flip
chart and it coming out as well and
being paired with the Wallach Revolution
I think it's a great pairing with the
two of those books being sold together
and they will be in physical form that
you can have it in hand and we will also
have the flip chart itself in a digital
download so that it can be purchased
and then used and as a projection to a
larger screen for for an actual
presentation to an audience so that's
something Dr Wallach a lot of people
have been asking for in our community
and I'm excited that I'm part of putting
that together for for them and you
so you get Triple A plus we can't thank
you enough because I know you're working
on some day and night
like you you know
a year in prison for a while like where
fortunately I was able to go home every
night and part of that in education was
working with computer Graphics so I
never dreamed that I'd be able to use
some of those skills
um but I'm glad that I have them and I'm
able to use them
to uh to help a
purpose better that's bigger than myself
so
thank you Dr Wallach for all of that and
you had referred to prions and not ever
seeing a prion you know they have some
really
colorful interesting artist Impressions
illustrations and that's it they're just
illustrations they came from the artist
said that was probably some scientist
saying oh I want a pry on
draw me something
but you're absolutely right when you and
I were searching
we didn't find anything that was real
life
so folks just because there's a pretty
picture of something doesn't mean that
it's true it's like cartoons all the
things that you think about in a cartoon
and all the things that happen in those
childhood cartoons
yeah there's very little in some of
these pictures these artists have drawn
Becca they're like
multi-colored ribbons in in coils and
stuff like that this is what this is
what their version of Kion is and they
expect you to believe that that's a
living bug no way
yeah I mean different shapes different
sizes different colors different lengths
some spirals some just wavy it's like
yeah I'm not buying Dr Wallach so and
the nice thing about it folks is
there's a lot that you can do
nutritionally
and when you give the body what it needs
the body
can do it
it can
utilize that nutrition to be the best
optimal self that let me interrupt here
because I didn't get into that
um when you have these emailing diseases
Alzheimer's disease MS or Jamboree
syndrome Parkinson's disease FTD like
Bruce Willis has
um chronic
um uh coinfield Jacob's disease ALS
amantra Lou Gehrig's Disease all that
kind of stuff what you want to do of
course
just take the health band and heart pack
take the MSM take the synaptive take the
I-26 which is a source of good
cholesterol to help rebuild the white
matter in the brain
and we have been seeing in all these
different types of diseases
the positive results for this okay and
so we're putting all this together and
putting it together and putting it
together and it's coming it's going to
blow everybody's mind
okay and so we can't thank you enough
for all you do
well it's it's my honor and privilege Dr
Wallach
um to be able to help you here to be
able to be the hostess of the daily with
Doc uh zoom and also the director of
student services for The Institute of
holistic health which you are one of the
founding fathers
fathers of is how they are affected by
nutritional deficiencies and then also
the solutions to help change
so that deficiencies don't occur and the
body can actually then Thrive instead of
just barely survive so folks if you'd
like more information about the coaching
program you can go to
coachwithdoc.com that is
coachwithdoc.com and get more
information about the coaching program
the certified holistic health coach
program offered by The Institute of
holistic health
was there anything else you wanted to
touch on Dr Wallach
um well just uh this thing going on with
the deer is a big deal because you know
they keep these groups keep pushing to
destroy thousands of deer that don't
have
chronic wasting disease and it's never
been proven to be transmissible it's
actually
uh what is it what it is actually it's
uh Parkinson's disease and dear
okay it's the same pathology under the
microscope in the brain of the deer as
it is in People human beings and
Parkinson's
and so that'd be like saying okay now we
have all these people with Parkinson's
disease we got to you know execute them
because they might transmit it to other
people
that's how silly they're
well with it not being transmissible and
and I've looked at some of the studies
where they'll just find two or three in
a whole area
it doesn't make sense that two or three
have it Dr Wallach and then to say that
it's contagious
I mean because I know where where my
farm is I'll go down a two mile stretch
there'll be over 50 deer
and then the 50 deer and there's one or
two and they want to destroy the whole
herd because of that one or two but the
rest are fine
yeah well maybe he's like saying well
you got two people in your village it
was with some Parkinson's disease let's
destroy let's execute everybody in the
village so nobody gets Parkinson's
disease that's how silly that is
yeah well
it doesn't make any sense and as I said
in the introduction Dr walek when you
hear the information
it's Common Sense folks
if you've got one in fifty and nobody
else is having any type of symptoms it's
not contagious right
that is correct we go we got to look at
nutrition we got to look at something
else folks and when when you're really
looking deep into it and you look at
things like Dr Wallach is looking at
things the demyelinization I mean that
means that that myelin that protects the
brain that protects the nerves is going
away
and when it's how much what percentage
of it is cholesterol
oh a myelin 100 percent
in some places some place 75 some place
is 50 but never less than 50 percent
so if you eliminate cholesterol the good
cholesterol all together you're going to
be depleting that cholesterol that is
needed for protection now will that be
the question I would want to ask
uh Bruce Willis's family did the doctors
put him on cholesterol lowering
medication
is that why he has
um okay is that why he has the problem
he's got okay he's got FTD
that that is a very good question Dr
Wallach and folks that's a good question
for anyone that is on any type of
cholesterol lowering drug what other
things do you have going on that could
be
contributed to yes a side effect
so all right well Dr Wallach I do have
to not forget to say that the content of
this program is to provide
educational information only on the
importance of nutrition it is not meant
to take the place of your primary care
physician nor are the products that Dr
Wallach mentions are designed to treat
prevent cure any diseases but folks when
you give the body what it needs the body
itself can do some amazing things
because of Divine Design
now as an empowered individual you can
make choices and as you're listening
through today's program we hope that it
will just give you a little more tool in
your toolbox to be able to make better
choices for yourself and if you hear
about
something in the program and it makes
you think of somebody that you know
whether it's somebody that you love or
just an acquaintance please feel free to
share this program with them you were
not listening to this program
by accident there is a purpose and it
may be that the purpose is that you can
help give somebody else a better outlook
on life and a better opportunity for a
better health Journey
now Dr Wallach we do have some hands up
so let's go ahead and go right over to
questions and folks again if you would
like to join us live in the zoom room
you can go to daily with Doc zoom.com
so first let's go to
Cindy Cindy go ahead and unmute yourself
can you hear me yes ma'am oh my God I'm
live again I was inviting people and I
couldn't get back in and I got oh my God
yes I'm just so honored to be a coach Dr
Wallach I am your Warrior you march into
100 you have blessed me for over 50
years even though I haven't done the 30
I've been researching you and every time
I tell somebody they said but I know him
do you really know him I said oh yeah
he's saved gonna instrumental in saving
my life that I have a client
and what I'm doing now is I'm getting a
lot of the because I'm an educator and
so I'm getting a lot of the parents and
kids and you know you said plant that
Garden so I did that and I'm getting
some of the 50 and older in the group so
I'm so excited I can barely talk but
real quick I have a every category she
would probably meet but she encountered
um an issue with high blood pressure she
is
um 70 years old
she's about five eight between five
eight and five nine and on her
evaluation
uh it says they couldn't find anything
because she is on our protocol but they
said her blood pressure was high but
when she spent the night in the hospital
it was low but they had put her on tons
of medications
she chose only to take the blood
pressure so I told her to stick with
what Dr Wallach said but they still
wanted her to do the blood pressure so I
said did they check all of your
categories so they said now her blood is
low and her hereditary Mark says it's
not a simple shape but
she's a woman of color but it's shaped
so that her blood is extremely low I
said well what is your hematocrit she
said oh they said it's 29. I said huh
that sounds close to normal so if you
can kind of address the red blood cells
on how I can just coach her on building
those up because she's done the
categories she's like a 80 something but
when I ask questions of what the doctors
did to her it takes her down about 30
points from our evaluation so I'm gonna
revisit that in 30 days
I didn't get how much she weighed well
she weighed 150 pounds but she lost 45
pounds fooling with the doctors for the
last year so she's about 105 110 and
she's pretty tall and thin now so she
needs to get some muscle mass back
and I've been doing everything with her
because I faced something similar and
now I'm finding more people
who are going through the same thing and
it saddens me that they can be doing
what we're doing and I did at the MSM
because I talked to you yesterday and
asked about the kidneys so she's good to
go it's just that they keep trying to
tell her you need to see a um what is it
a blood doctor so he can tell you why
your blood is low in its shape so
I have a lot of views on that but I
won't touch that I'll let you handle
that if we can get her blood red blood
let me step in here yes sir thank you
for laying out this information well
basically at uh 105 pounds uh she needs
to get rid of all the bad foods you know
fried foods no processed Meats oils or
glutens the Wheaton oats so buckwheat no
sugar no carbonated or drinks even
carbonated diet drinks and also the
carbonated water needed to go and then
at 105 pounds I wanted to have one
healthy brain and heart pack half of
those everything twice a day and here
take the
MSM on one bottle a month so you take
three breakfasts three at dinner time
that's going to support and promote
Mainstreet pair of cartilage lumens
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone makes bone Salvage
including the bone marrow okay which
makes the red blood cells and platelets
and white blood cells and and also
antibodies and uh that sort of stuff
okay and
um so the you know the bone marrow makes
the red blood cells and then we need her
also to be on the I'd go with the
collagen peptides you can go ahead and
take a scuba that with their morning
drinks or their evening drink
and let's see here about the I-26 can we
add that well yeah we're going to add
the I-26 absolutely she doesn't even if
she doesn't have any symptoms right now
but her age and all this other stuff
going on I-26 you go ahead and have two
servings a day of that and we have the
chewables we have the capsules we have
the powder of the I-26 and it has to
rebuild the myelin and then with the
hybrid pressure
um we we should have her take the um
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice a day that's two
bottles a month they're small bottles uh
ultimate daily classic
and uh don't if she's on high blood
pressure medication don't cold turkey
have the blood pressure medication but
as the blood pressure drops you can
still reduce the medication based on the
numbers
and the red blood cells will be built
normally in the bone marrow uh as long
as she's getting all these nutrients the
bone marrow makes red blood cells makes
white blood cells right and uh and so
forth
and it doesn't eat meat sheet but she
does get our plant-based um protein
powder so the doctor did suggest you do
maybe a steak a week and
she said if possibly she might but that
would be only thing she'd consider for a
little bit to build up what about what
about fish when she eat salmon or Cod or
anything like that
well she said maybe but the water was
too hot outside now so the fish are
dying and she's a little bit
leery of the fish so
um I'll suggest that and um see how that
looks because she reminds me so much of
other clients that I'm getting and and
it's just kind of and I told him you
know even in the house with the gluten
if everyone's not gluten that'll still
be some hindrance but
at least if she can control herself and
do all in the efas I told her make sure
you know yeah don't forget those all the
daily classic tablets she could take
twice a day and that's going to help her
with the blood pressure okay I'm gonna
go too low because she said normally if
she's not stressed it's about 120 over
75 but then if she gets excited it goes
up to about 150 uh her systolic so I
don't know
and she takes that little pink pill
okay so let's go and you know
walk through this I will I'll check her
again in a couple of weeks and see what
we agree thank you sir thank you Cindy
yeah this is It's A Beautiful story and
of course it's nice to have uh people
who are coaches like this who just love
to help others and and it's a wonderful
thing okay
absolutely
thank you Cindy and let's go over to
Maryland Marilyn go ahead and unmute
yourself do you have a question from our
audience
well I have one from a client of mine
he's had ongoing diarrhea issues before
he
um got on Dr wallach's protocol and then
I told him to reduce doshas and uh
concentrate on this diet fasting that
type of thing he still seems to have
issues now Dr Wallach you have talked
about possible diarrhea from
osteoporosis of the skull I was
wondering if you could explain a little
bit about that how that happens okay
well as she approaches go the skull
squeezes the spinal cord and the spinal
cord is telling
the the
gastrointestinal system what to do the
stomach intestines and all this kind of
stuff so it's a skeleton squeezing the
spinal cord and saying go to the
bathroom now you're going to go to the
bathroom okay and so that's that's how
that's how that works and so
um but also I need to make sure there's
no bad foods no fried foods no processed
meat some oils no glutens the wheat no
butter and oats though buckwheat now
there's no gluten in buckwheat but
buckwheat has phagopyarines which are 10
times worse I wouldn't hurt to get the
book the doctor likes to cook him out
the bad foods 300 pages of safe recipes
and has a good food bad food list in
there okay and uh wouldn't hurt to kind
of review all that kind of information
what's the nerve that's possibly being
pinched to
it's important
oh it's just into the spinal cord the
nerves that going through the sprinkler
yeah the spinal cord
because he starts in the brain comes out
through the foramen magnum which is
Latin for big hole okay and that's when
when you get asked the approaches the
skull the skull squeezes that spinal
cord there and when you look at the
pictures okay I can find it really
quickly here
which one do you want
Dr Wally
I got the picture okay yeah the picture
of the the entire body
okay in this y'all as you can see where
the skull will be squeezing the spinal
cord everything Downstream is affected
by the skull squeezing the spinal cord
whether it's your
um nerves and the arms the nerves going
to the heart the nerves going to the
lungs and the nerves go into the
diaphragm the nurse going to the
um uh going to the
ninth cranle nerve or swallowing and
talking and voice and everything like
that
and then of course you get the sciatica
and this can be caused by the skull
squeezing the spinal cord causing
sciatica because when the spinal cord
gets down to your sacrum it splits to
get a sciatic nerve in the right and the
side nerve on the left and the problems
when you get
what
um a pain and numbness and tingling in
your toes the doctors want to amputate
your toes well that could be the brain
excuse me the skull squeezing the spinal
cord up at the top here and why would
you want to cut off normal toes
because your skull is squeezing your
spinal cords
perfect great it's all a system thank
you yep appreciate it
all right thank you Marilyn
and folks if you are interested in
getting any of Dr wallach's books please
go to d r j wallick.com that is d r j
wallick.com
and Theodis go ahead and unmute yourself
unmute unmute
here we go here we go uh doc that's
always impresses me how many issues
relate to osteoporosis of the skull even
throughout the whole body that's just
incredible
we have a question from Facebook from
Saul
um regarding a woman 30 years old
five foot five
and 138 pounds
and the question for her how can she
recover after having a second
miscarriage
miscarriage causing sepsis
okay so she had an infection after the
miscarriage apparently okay well I'd be
concerned about why she had the
miscarriage and so here's a case where
you have to appreciate sit down think
about it
Gotta Give It All the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meas no oils no
gluten so we've been around oh so
buckwheat no sugar no carbonated drinks
you know the diet drinks and also the
carbonated water got to go and this is
this is for everybody in the entire
family okay because they get
cross-contaminated in the laundry and
the couches and the beds and the rugs
and chairs and so forth but also
this gal here at um let's see here
it's uh 138 pounds right okay correct
okay so we want her to have I'd go with
two healthy brain and heart pasture
month to follow those things twice a day
so she's eating for two people now if
she wants to have a normal birth okay
um then we need to find out did the
babies have birth defects when they were
uh aborted or they're just aborted okay
do they have a cleft palate do they have
a heart defect or you know what's going
on there okay and then uh these are not
caused by genetics these are caused by
nutritional deficiencies okay and so
that's why you know the big
hard pack
uh two of those per month uh two bottles
of a month of the MSM so you can take
three breakfasts three lunch at dinner
time
um let's see here two small canisters of
the collagen peptides as you could take
a scuba them in the morning drinks or
the evening drink and then she needs our
rebounder sports drink instead of the
colas and the Pepsis and the and the
Seven ups and all that kind of stuff all
that's got to go use our rebound sports
drink it's another 100 nutrients in our
sports drink there are 75 metals and 25
volumes amino acids
and let's see here
um also it wouldn't hurt to take get a
hair analysis and find out if she's
absorbing okay get it here analysis get
the book rarest man cures go to page 272
chapters 10 11 it tells you how to
collect the hair where to ship it uh how
to package it and so on don't forget to
put the check in there otherwise the lab
won't run the test I actually got toxic
metals or if she's deficient certain
nutrients
and so she's had two miscarriages
there's something very Sinister going on
there okay
well we can all appreciate how expectant
mothers not only do they need the 90
nutrients what you're recommending
actually repairs and rebuilds the body
gives it energy and vitality so that the
woman can carry a baby that's correct
thanks back to you Becca
all right thank you Phyllis and let's
move over to Breck Rick go ahead and
unmute yourself
I think you got it how are you today oh
nope let's try one more time
I'm doing great Becca doing great Dr
Wallach how you doing on one of your
health coaches I appreciate the
opportunity being part of your army well
thank you for being there we appreciate
you and all the great stuff you do how
can we help you today
I actually have a lady I'm working with
Dr Wallach she's a 50 year old female
five foot six 170 pounds this woman has
been suffering since January after
having a car accident she's been
diagnosed with cervical spine impact
injury and hasn't had any relief at all
hasn't been able to sleep turn her neck
anything nobody can find out
um
you know after this car accident what
the problem is she has an interesting uh
issue as well extremely dehydrated and
drinks a lot of water but can't seem to
get hydrated at all so a dehydration
problem as well
okay well at 170 pounds she needs to get
rid of all the bad foods okay no fried
food or processed meat some oils or
glutens and wheat so buckwheat no sugar
no carbonated drinks including this the
soft drinks as well as the carbonated
water
um let's see needs the
um I go ahead with the
uh let's see I said the two healthy man
hard packs
um to the MSM so you can take three of
breakfast three lunch three dinner time
to support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc which means
itself
and again it sounds like she may have
osteoporosis of the skull it was really
hammered when she had that accident and
so they're looking here at her neck but
this stuff is going on up here in the
skull so they need to they need to do an
an MRI not a not an x-ray but an MRI of
a skull to see if she's got osteoporosis
of the skull okay okay and then we won
her also to have the the collagen
peptides and scuba that in their morning
drinks you have an evening drink
we want her to have the uh as I said the
rebounder sports drinks you can have two
doses a day of that as her body weight
okay you use a CM cream on her neck in
the back of her skull okay that's going
to relieve inflammation but I'd be very
very interested
um to know before she had the accident
how many times she's waking up at night
to urinate one is three times five times
ten times
um does she have rain in her ears does
she have a balance problem okay did she
lose her sense of smell did she have
difficulty in swallowing did her voice
change does she lose her sense of taste
we need to know all that stuff
to find out if she had obviously
approaches a skull before the car
accident and was she driving was she the
driver
she was a passenger actually her and her
husband but she's the one that took the
brunt of it okay okay so yeah let's find
out more information but let's get her
started there
and uh wouldn't it wouldn't hurt to do a
hair analysis I had to find out if she's
got toxic metals and find out if she's
got um any
um
she's just low on some of the essential
minerals okay
sure I appreciate it Dr Wallach thank
you okay brick thank you so much I look
forward to working some more with you I
appreciate it thanks
all right thank you so much Breck for
coming on so Dr Wallach
um
I have a little girl she's four years
old at 40 pounds
she has done some allergy testing turns
out she's allergic to all shellfish
sesame seeds peanuts sunflowers pumpkin
seeds Brazil nuts and more
now I personally know this little girl
she's not a junk food eat dog eater
doctor wall like they use lots of fruits
lots of vegetables
can allergies like this be caused by
something nutritionally
is there something that can be done to
help her overcome this what what can we
do for allergies well we need to get a
hair analysis to find out what's going
on there
okay okay
if she's got toxic Metals if she's got
some uh deficiencies and stuff that'll
show up in the hearing analysis okay
again the book rare Earthman occurs
chapters 10 11 page 272 tells you how to
collect the hair how to package it where
to ship it don't forget to put the check
in there because the lab will run the
test without it
so we need some lab work uh here to find
out what's going on uh in the meantime
it won't hurt you know for her to based
on her body weight 40 pounds she can
have
um one of our kids tatties per day she'd
have one of those per day okay then she
could have one of our rebounds per day
then she needs two
or three
meals with a something like the
healthiest art pack okay or the hell the
brain and heart attack whichever one the
family wants to do and she's 40 pounds
would be a half a dose every day okay
but she doesn't swallow pills I know the
brain and heart pack has two different
types of efas and selenium so what are
your recommendations for grind them up
you grind them up and put them in
applesauce
okay
all right
um and then I don't think she has an egg
allergy would the I-26 be beneficial for
her it cannot hurt to do the I-26
because we have the chewables that's
good for her the chewables there uh
they're soft chewables we have the
French vanilla and the banana coconut
I'd go with the chewables and her body
weight she could have one or two of
those three times a day
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and we have a question that is
coming in
regards to endometrial lining and
thickening of the lining
um 27 years old
123 pounds
and she says she has the thickening of
the lining she also has polyps and
ovarian cysts Dr Wallach
no blood sugar issues and no blood
pressure issues okay
um so I want to know what she's eating
okay we need a hair analysis on her is
she eating spaghetti at lunch every day
is she eating buckwheat pancakes for
breakfast okay she's getting some
interference with absorption and
creating a lot of inflammation okay and
then we want her at 123 pounds we want
her to have well
[Music]
um
with all that going on there the
finances are not an issue I would go
with two Health brand hard packs if if
finances are an issue I wouldn't go
below one healthy brand hardback I guess
at least one healthy Brandon hard pack
and half a dose of everything twice a
day
MSM she could start out with one bottle
of MSM take three breakfast free dinner
time okay and then also
um she needs to take our
um
is there a fem x e r a dash fem that's
gonna give her ovaries the nutrients it
needs to make estrogen and progesterone
and all the hormones and proper amounts
and so forth
so let's start there but let's get a
hair analysis and find out what's going
on because we got all this stuff going
on there uh sounds to me like she's
getting some bad foods and not getting
the good foods and so is she eating bad
foods or is she just getting
cross-contaminated in the laundry in the
home okay or does she you know work in a
place it as you work in a bakery I mean
who knows what's going on there
right
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and then we have a question
wanting to know whatever happened to
your research
um that was done
on the wreaths and the ocean
okay uh well then came
covered okay coverage so we were we were
ready to go we had finished everything
we collected all the data we know why
the reefs are dying okay and we know how
to deal with it and
um
we know why the oceans are dying we know
how to deal with it it's just a matter
of
priorities okay and so the governments
made the code the priorities
okay and so it's you know we'd have to
come up with 10 billion dollars to do it
out of our own pocket and I said nobody
I know has 10 billion dollars to spend
on a reef okay but see when you start
jamming up the rivers and the streams to
make electricity hydroelectric and all
that kind of stuff all those minerals
are coming down in the streams don't get
to the ocean anymore
um
so water's flowing gets jammed up
everything heavy sinks so at the bottom
of those dams
which were built for electricity you
know the turn of the century okay and so
um
and of course
um it Afflicted the bottomlands as you
can fix it all the places were depending
on the minerals coming down from the
mountains
and so our sources of the land flowing
and milk and honey disappeared
because of the hydroelectric dams
all right so Dr Wallach if that's
everything all the good stuff
stands how do we get
that Downstream okay well basically
um some clever guys started collecting
all that Silk behind the dams and you
know put them in drying it and putting
it in in the bags and selling it so
there's a certain amount in small
amounts of being sold for local
fertilizers and that kind of stuff but
big
projects to save the to say the um Coral
have not developed okay and so it's one
of those things where
um we know what to do
uh the technology is we already have the
technology it's not like it's a mystery
but priorities priorities priorities and
of course the government's made
um the priority
to um make vaccinations
for covid
all right well Dr Wallach it is time for
you to go to your next program thank you
so much I think that's a good place to
to end our program today we greatly
appreciate you and all that you do as
you know a researcher a scientist a
veterinarian and a naturopathic
physician and a pathologist well thank
you
you're very welcome have a very blessed
day and we will see you tomorrow here on
daily with Doc
all right bye Dr Wallach and if I could
get my co-hosts on the screen with me I
could not do this without them as
they're Fielding questions and going
through making sure that I get questions
put up in front of me also so we try not
to miss anything folks but we are
um well we're excited that there are so
many people asking questions that we run
out of questions during the program in
fact I've got hundreds of questions that
have been emailed in and I just want to
continue to
um encourage you
to go to our website daily withdoc.com
use that contact us or sign up for our
newsletter and enter in your questions I
do have
several certified holistic health
coaches that I am sharing and having
them help me answer these questions
based on Dr wallach's research so you
should be getting answers back
and if we don't know the answer we have
direct connections with the man who does
Dr Joel Wallach I just want to do shout
out for my team that I have on with me
today we have Phyllis who has been with
Dr Wallach since almost the very very
beginning and has been very instrumental
her and her husband Andy both and
getting Dr Wallach on the radio and
syndicated with the Dead Doctors Don't
Lie show Phyllis is just doing a great
job and folks Phyllis you can answer
this would you continue to do what you
do if you did not believe in something
because it worked
uh not sure I quite understood the
question but I'll never stop doing this
because I know it works does does that
answer
that answers just right
so Phyllis is our just right person she
is absolutely fabulous and folks it 27
years I think Phyllis has been with Dr
Wallach and just helping to continue the
message so having that confidence and
continuing on is is just speaks volumes
to me so I'm very proud to have her on
with us as well and then we have sherry
who is coming with us uh with several
different certifications from several
different organizations and being as a
coach for many many years and then
adding in the nutrition that Dr Wallach
speaks of and having her clients
continually get better and refer refer
refer
that's that's what this is all about
because we as individuals can only do so
much but folks when you get on a program
and you feel results and you start
sharing results with others and
referring those people that's how we're
going to build stronger communities so I
just want to thank Sherry for all she
does
um as as an amazing person and helping
bring get people into the show and
watching cameras we just every every
little bit folks is important when it
comes to putting on a program like this
and we have Marilyn who is very diligent
at taking and doing dictation of what Dr
Wallach is recommending and putting it
into the chat which is one of the big
bonuses of
having the live zoom and you being able
to join us here Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time
because you get to see the information
that that Marilyn is putting in there
but there was is always putting stuff in
there as well so is Sherry and so is
Ruth Ellen my executive production
manager as she's sharing information and
making sure everything goes smoothly as
she's keeping keeping an eye on so many
different things I just want to say
thank you Ruth Ellen so much for all
that you do and a lot of the things that
are behind the scene that nobody even
knows about but me
um and AJ so and then we go to AJ the
assistant to the executive production
manager who is making sure that we're
getting all of our streams
um out to where people are we want to
meet you where you're at so folks if
you're on any platform that you're
listening to this program you're
watching this program and there's a way
that you can comment
comment let us know where you are
joining us and listening or watching
from so that we know that our message is
getting out and don't forget to share as
a thank you to you for sharing
I do have a giveaway that's going on go
to
dwdgiveaway.com that's
dwdgiveaway.com and or register for our
giveaway go to the different platforms
that you participate in and make sure
that you look for our Channel like our
Channel or share our Channel
and because you get points for both and
those with the most points will be
getting thank you gifts from myself and
the team so AJ is helping me get all of
that stuff set up and I just want to say
thank you chop liver AJ
um
you put a comment
um in the chat that uh just yeah so
folks we have fun here we are a family
we work together and if you were invited
by somebody specific they're also part
of the family but we want you to make
sure that you get back with them thank
them for taking the time to share this
program with you and ask them how do I
get started
I
you know share with the person I share
this program with you say you know I
have this this and this going on do you
know what I need do you know how to get
a hold of what Dr Wallach would
recommend for me chances are they do so
give them the opportunity to do that if
you found this program on your very own
nobody shared in this information with
you as a personal friend or or what have
you
please go to daily withdoc.com you can
use that contact option to reach us or
you can call our call team
855-949-3377 that's
855-949-3377 and that call team is for
those who are not already working with
somebody or a youngevity customer we
want to make sure that we keep the
Integrity of the organization and have
you get back with the person that you
originally purchased from or have spoken
with
folks my name is Becca Dukes again as
the hostess of this program and also the
director of student services for The
Institute of holistic health it is my
honor and privilege and because I have
felt the difference my calling to make
sure that you have the opportunity to
feel the difference as well until next
time
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]